incertidumbre en el continente americano
por la viruela del mono a medida que
crece el número de infectados en Estados
Unidos incrementa la demanda de vacunas
en Nueva Jersey las dosis disponibles se
agotan el mismo día allí una iniciativa
de salud comunitaria promueve la
inmunización contra la enfermedad
ha venido una cantidad asombrosa de
personas en el día se agotan las vacunas
que tengamos disponibles por ejemplo 200
400 vacunas si tuviéramos mil vacunas
las utilizamos ese mismo día la demanda
es muy alta
y es que esta semana el departamento de
salud y servicios humanos aumentó el
stock de vacunas listas para entregar en
más de 400.000 a pesar de esto los
estadounidenses están preocupados porque
la cantidad suministrada no satisface la
demanda Mientras tanto al sur de Perú
aumenta la preocupación según la
asociación médica el país cuenta con la
mayor cantidad de pacientes en América
Latina hemos estado documentando las
lesiones y viviendo el tratamiento y nos
hemos estado dando cuenta de que
cerca del 90% de casos son pacientes
que han adquirido la enfermedad por un
contacto que puede ser sexual o no
sexual
prácticamente todos son hombres
salvo una mujer que es un personal de
salud que accidentalmente se contagió
hasta el 15 de agosto Perú había
confirmado 834 casos en uno de sus
hospitales el 90% de los infectados
padece VIH la viruela del mono provocado
brotes en al menos 90 países sumando
unos 36.000 casos lo que llevó a la OMS
a declarar la emergencia internacional